hey guys anna welcome back to the leia
hill fan show this particular episode is
sponsored by exodus wallet so a huge
thank you to exodus wallet because
without them we wouldn't be able to
bring you such brilliant content so
exodus wallet is a next generation
digital marketplace and cryptocurrency
wallet it's available on desktop it's
available on mobile it's also available
on iphone android it's easy to use easy
to download and to be honest is my
number one top pick when it comes to
cryptocurrency wallets
joining me today is the one and only
mayor of miami frances suarez frances
how are you i'm wonderful thank you so
much it's great to have you thank you so
much for joining me
miami is a really interesting place i've
been here for about two months now and
the first thing that i noticed as soon
as i arrived was the intense
entrepreneurial spirit
everybody is building there's so much
innovation and it's quite unprecedented
given the times we're living in so
firstly i just want to start by saying
thank you essentially for allowing um
this this environment to flourish well i
appreciate it and you're right you know
we do we are extremely entrepreneurial
what's changed is that you know we used
to be sort of a small business mecca and
that's great that's wonderful because
small business powers this country
empowers the world but i think now we've
learned the power of scale and i think
that makes us dangerous right in the
sense that we have the ability now to
tap into what other big markets across
the world have tapped into which is the
ability to to start something and make
it something that's ubiquitous that's
that's used and that solves problems you
know for the entirety of humanity and
that's really exciting and i think you
know when you see that happening in your
city when you see your city transforming
when you realize your city's on the
forefront like you said of innovation
the forefront of the future
you know that you're creating an
ecosystem and an economy that not only
serves my generation but serves my
children and my unborn grandchildren
it's such a pleasure to be here and be
part of the energy and to feel it all
but speaking of being on the forefront
of innovation this really started kind
of about a year ago because you made
that infamous tweet somebody asked um
you know can we make miami like silicon
valley and you said how can i help so
talk me through this why did you want to
help and what is it really that you see
for miami that you wanted to change well
we had really been trying for 10 years
to create this technological ecosystem
the reason why is because we know that
the economy of the future is going to be
driven by technology whether we like
technology or we don't no matter what
party you're from no matter what issues
you may think that that exists in
technology it's it's it's a reality and
it's a reality that we could either as a
city we can run from or we can embrace
and so we've decided to embrace it
because we know that's a pathway to
prosperity for our citizens we know
that's going to create high-paying jobs
in our community and it's already doing
it so what happened was we had been
building this economy sort of slowly
like a small business you know
bootstrapped with friends and family
money and then all of a sudden on
december 4th we had this sort of ipo
moment where we we shot like a rocket to
the moon and the kpi since then are off
the charts we're number one in the
nation in tech job growth number one in
the nation in tech job migration
according to pitchbook uh we went up uh
like billions of dollars in vc money
from one year to the next i think it was
a 50 growth in one year uh we've we've
brought like a trillion dollars of
assets under management companies to the
city of miami and and created thousands
of high-paying jobs so we've done that
all in one year which just goes to show
how disruptive this world is and how you
know a city that maybe wasn't talked
about in tech is now the city that's
most talked about in tech absolutely you
guys are leading now when it comes to
cryptocurrency so let's go into all of
that i think what's unique about you as
a mayor is that i feel you really
understand and really grasp the
frustration that people in the
cryptocurrency community have with the
traditional financial system so from
your perspective what would you say some
of the key issues is that
cryptocurrencies like bitcoin are
actually solving
well you i think you articulate very
well which is the fact that in a modern
day world if you have money in a bank
account you're not earning any interest
and we're an incredibly inflationary uh
economy not just in the us but across
the world and so you're literally losing
purchasing power every single day that
your money is sitting idle and so that
means that you have to look at options
and what are the options that you have
and i think
one of the things that people don't talk
enough about is with bitcoin the market
has already
taken a look at bitcoin looked at its
fundamentals and priced it against the
dollar whether it's 60 000 or whether
it's 50 000 it still takes 50 000 us
dollars to buy one bitcoin so the market
has
it created a tremendous amount of
confidence in that system which is
a system that cannot be manipulated by
human beings and it's a system that's
open and transparent
that is incredibly powerful and so you
know i know that
people that don't like bitcoin what i
call the haters right they will point to
the volatility of bitcoin and my view of
it is you know i'm not a day trader i'm
not here trying to trying to trade up
and down based on a price one day or
another i'm holding a currency or an
asset or a digital asset because of its
fundamentals and because of where i
think it's going to go and i think when
you look at its performance uh over time
it's certainly outperformed inflation
and certainly outperformed so many other
assets i'm sure that i don't think
there's many asset classes that have
outperformed bitcoin and so it's it's
it's really just a phenomenon like
you see these technological phenomenas
when we went from trading marbles to
gold from gold to you know dollars
backed by gold to dollars not backed by
gold and fiat currencies it's just
another evolution in the way that we as
human beings are going to transact
business and you mentioned inflation
there and we were told um by the by the
federal reserve that inflation is
transitory that's kind of the the idea
and the sentiment but it's clearly not
the case and so there seems to be a lot
of hostility um from the senate from the
government from all sorts of
institutions um towards cryptocurrency
so how do you see the the two the
traditional system and cryptocurrencies
working alongside each other do you
think that's possible
you know to answer the first question i
think the federal government i think has
already started to walk back the idea
that it's transitory you know you have
um you know a ton of money which has
been
put into the circulation or in the money
supply through excess government
spending and then you have supply chain
shortages uh which are conspiring to
create this sort of perfect storm and i
think a lot of people believe that the
cpi is under reporting inflation i think
cpi is only at six percent uh people
when you consider housing costs and
other things that may not be in the
basket of goods to the cpi think it's
significantly higher so i think that's
that's that's a big part of it and what
was the second question i forgot oh okay
so the second part of the question is
how do you see the two systems working
alongside each other given the hostility
that we have seen you know i think right
now they're working alongside of each
other but i think that there's a real
possibility a real possibility that one
can completely disrupt the other one
and and i think obviously crypto
disrupting sort of the fiat legacy
system right that you would say i think
what you might see that disruption uh
happen faster is in areas of
hyperinflation like we're seeing a lot
of inflation in the us but frankly the
u.s dollar is still you know considered
to be you know an important currency but
when you look at central america south
america and even africa you're looking
at areas that are ripe for disruption
where people could have more confidence
potentially trading satoshis as opposed
to whatever the currency of their of
their country is
and they can do it in a peer-to-peer
format and and if they can get out of
the
control structure of what government
tries to do um then i think we can see
not only bitcoin being something that
metamorphosis from store value into a
currency but we can see it as a
liberating force and that's something
that gets me really excited when i think
about the landscape of what the future
of our world can look like but given how
disruptive you imagine it's going to be
how did your colleagues take to your new
innovative stance and how did you
basically convince them
you know
my colleagues have been very supportive
a lot of them by the way in sort of my
parents generation and you know some of
them said like hey we trust you like we
trust you to do this so i think that's
been part of it then the our other part
of it is the results have been good
right like when you know when you see
uh someone innovating and things work
out you you create confidence right you
create credibility and i think they've
seen that in me they've seen you know
the virality of what this moment has
created for miami we've become a cr you
know i think we're the crypto capital of
the world so we brought thank you we
brought uh ftx here they did a 200
million dollar naming deal
blockchain.com located headquarters here
etoro israeli uh exchange located at
headquarters here xbto and we brought
the bitcoin conference from la 50 000
attendees we're gonna do it again next
april so we have i think change the
center of gravity uh uh you know from
some of the mega markets to what i can
what i call as the epicenter of capital
or the capital of capital where we're
right in the middle of europe the middle
east you know uh new york south america
and the silicon valley no one of those
mega markets is closer to each other
than they are to miami and so i think
that uh puts us in a unique position to
sort of metamorphosize and graduate from
being the same you know the capital of
latin america to being the epicenter of
capital this is i'm just in awe of what
you're doing it's so refreshing to hear
maya speak like this and obviously
you're taking your salary and bitcoin
that is absolutely wild so
why firstly um how from a practical
standpoint and obviously are you not
concerned about the volatility i'm not
and so the why and how the why is
because you know we have to keep
innovating we have to always stay ahead
of the curve we have to sort of set the
narrative the how's simple we use an app
called strike which is really easy to
use and anyone can use it though do am i
afraid of volatility the answer is no
and the reason why is because and i have
to say in full disclosure that my
mayoral salary is not my only salary so
as a mayor in miami-dade accounting most
of the mayors have outside income i have
a you know a sort of private sector life
and so it's not my full income and so
you know i i don't necessarily think
that someone should necessarily put
their full income in it but i do think
you know something that is reasonable in
terms of what they want to invest they
want to diversify their portfolio they
want to save money in a particular asset
a digital asset like bitcoin you know
that's something that i feel comfortable
with and so you also have to lead by
example in life you know uh and i think
uh that creates a level of excitement
you know when i was the first person uh
first elected official in america to get
covered you know when i did a diary uh
it made people feel at ease because they
saw me dealing with it and struggling
with it in a very public way and so i
think that uh that taught me that you
know transparency and and putting
yourself out there is something can be
very rewarding i think it's really
rewarding and i think people actually
pick that up um from you um yeah you
know it instills more confidence in
miami and everything that you say but of
course that is the goal it's a great
it's it's working so there's also miami
coin
so that is also crazy talk to me about
miami coin and how it works and also
where the value of it comes from sure so
miami coin is a bitcoin based uh
technology right and the reason why is
because it's created out of the stacks
blockchain which hashes onto the bitcoin
blockchain obviously we all know the
bitcoin blockchain is the most
decentralized and secure blockchain on
the planet and so there's an interaction
between bitcoin stocks and then this
coin that was created through stacks
which is essentially a smart contract uh
which is miami coin and miami coin what
it does which is similar and different
with bitcoin in bitcoin when you mine a
bitcoin the miner gets 100 percent of
the revenue as well they should they're
the ones that they're the authenticating
mechanism for this network in miami coin
30 of the mining revenue goes into a
digital wallet for miami and so for the
city whatever the city it is whether
it's miami new york or whatever they've
already established new york corn so
uh we thought you know if it generates
three million or five million dollars in
a year that'd be super successful it's
generated over 20 million dollars in
four months
so
the the you know the the fact that we
have created a brand has gotten people
to invest and to and to and and to
believe in something like miami coin and
where its value is going to be and i
think similar to you know bitcoin i do
think there will be massive utility uh
models into 2022 i think if 2020 thing i
think is the year of the mainstreaming i
think 2022 will be the year of utility
can you give us some examples of utility
for miami coin sure uh one of the things
that i would say is you know and i think
this is the same for bitcoin we want to
get to a point where you can go in and
buy a snickers with bitcoin right like
who when is that moment gonna happen and
so i think you know for miami coin not
too dissimilar from bitcoin if it's
liquid which it is you know you can go
into a restaurant you can you can get a
meal in a miami restaurant maybe you get
a discount for using a miami coin and so
i've had a lot of people come to me with
you know utility ideas and how they can
collaborate with miami coin um and so
we're going to be unveiling some of
those next year hopefully and so you
mine it an individual just becomes a
miner and they they get 70 of the of the
profits right so in in bitcoin in the
bitcoin mining world you get 100 of
profits you mine something right and the
offshoot of that mining if you solve the
mathematical problem to authenticate the
the transaction you get 100
in the case of miami coin you get 70
and the 30 of what is essentially the
pot goes uh to the cities in a digital
wallet so i read at one point you guys
were offering or not you but miami coin
the network was offering 430 apy i think
it's now around just over 100 apy how
does that work talk to me about how
that's even possible so the way it works
is it depends on how people are
investing in the coin so it's a totally
different uh a proof mechanism than than
bitcoin the proof mechanism bitcoin of
course is proof of work so it and it's
based on splitting from satoshi's
formula in the case of miami coin you're
actually pledging coins and so the
derivative of that pledge is the mining
revenue and so that's why it can be a
higher yield than but the yield has gone
down which is is understandable and
expected uh it's not going to always be
400 everyone would would do that if that
were the case and so that that's coming
back down to earth but i still think
it's an attractive proposition and we're
going to stake our miami coin revenue
which is in is in stacks to hopefully
create a bitcoin yield so we can
actually give a bitcoin yield to all of
our residents in the city at least all
the ones that sign up yeah so two things
firstly it doesn't matter you know if
it's gone from 400 to 100 it's better
than negative interest rates which we
see across europe yeah exactly so talk
to me about that bitcoin dividend how
does that work how often is it paid out
and also can anybody get involved so for
example i'm obviously not a us citizen
but i'm trying to be a resident in 2022.
when can i get my bitcoin dividend yeah
you got to be in miami i will make that
so
there you go so the way it's going to be
is you know first we have to we have to
create what i call the universe right so
who is in miami how do you define me i
mean anybody can define themselves ma'am
and you can be in nebraska and say i'm a
miami so we had to come up with the
universe and i think the universe that
we're we're thinking of is people who
are registered voters in miami in the
city of miami so that's someone who who
we can we can verify we can define
and we know that they're engaged in some
sort of civic endeavor which hopefully
is voting right and it also promotes a
civic endeavor which is voting and so
that's that's part of it the second part
is is then we would we would offer them
hopefully an array of digital wallets
and we're working with some big
exchanges i can't say yeah because it
would ruin the surprise right that would
ex that would put uh miami coin on their
uh digital um you know on their
uh on their exchanges and would also
offer a digital wallet for our residents
to be able to receive the dividend in uh
bitcoin and so then the third thing is
how often will we do it i think we would
like to set it up in a quarterly fashion
because i think that you know we're
going to be constantly doing it we want
to do it sort of
you know make it the management cost a
reasonable and the sort of logistics of
it reasonable so i think that's what
we're looking at and we're you know
we're doing this for the first time so
we're sort of inventing the wheel if you
will yeah absolutely and you've actually
been called by a lot of tech
entrepreneurs i'm the ceo of miami which
i think is brilliant um given that
you're trying to recruit as much talent
to the city as possible and we've seen
um i think he's there now the
mayor-elect eric adams of um new york so
is there a competition going on there to
i don't know see who could become the
leading cryptocurrency city
well i am technically the ceo of the
city uh in the charter i'm the chief
executive officer but you know the mayor
and i have a friendship you know and
we've developed a friendship and and you
know for us it's about
we are we're the ones that are like like
you said we're not only the chief
executive officers we're chief marketers
of our city you know we want to present
the best image for our city we want to
give our residents the best chance to be
successful into the future and so when
you talk about you know new york
obviously their mayor is going to be
championing initiatives that he thinks
are going to put their city forward and
i think the fact that we've been able to
have this sort of fun back and forth is
a really positive thing for both of our
cities but more importantly it's a
positive thing for america because it
means that the our country
is maintaining itself on the forefront
of innovation which is not what china's
doing that's shutting down bitcoin
mining and shutting down bitcoin we're
taking advantage of the innovation that
other countries are maybe not taken
advantage of
and so in terms of miami then where do
you see it in the next five to ten years
you know like i said i've been playing
with this concept of our metamorphosis
right i think we're in a generational
inflection point in the history of not
just our country but the world and i
think miami is well positioned to come
out of that disruptive era and that
generational opportunity as one of the
most significant cities in the world and
i think part of it is our geolocation
part of it is our attitude and our
perspective of innovation um and you
know and part of it is our you know two
years like you said our entrepreneurial
work ethic spirit that's going to be
combined with people coming from the
outside and capital coming from the
outside that's going to create this
incredible mix that will have a two to
five to seven year horizon as as we
invest in ourselves and see that the
companies that are produced now today uh
are exiting in two and five and seven
years
mayor suarez i want to thank you so much
it's been such a pleasure speaking with
you um keep doing what you're doing i'm
loving it i can't wait to move here um
and i really appreciate everything that
you're creating we can't wait for you to
be a bitcoin dividend recipient thank
you so much
guys thank you so much for watching
thank you to exodus for sponsoring this
and please don't forget to subscribe and
hit like so you never miss a video
[Music]
you